[Musique]
m
en
[Musique]
mars 1962 les accords d'evian ouvre la
porte à l'indépendance algérienne en
échange de l'indépendance
les algériens font un certain nombre de
concessions notamment la possibilité
pour la france de continuer ses essais
nucléaires après 1962 au coeur des
montagnes du hoggar 3 1 0
rendement du sol soulève les poussières
accumulés par l'érosion sans cassure de
la montagne elles ne sont pas
radioactives les émanations sont en
permanence contrôler pour déceler tout
danger accidentelle jusqu'en 1966 la
france procédera à une douzaine d'essais
souterrain présenté comme moins
dangereux que les essais atmosphériques
nous et bulidon ingénieur chimiste de
formation s'est retrouvé dans un
laboratoire militaire en mai 1962 à in
eker son rôle contrôler la radioactivité
de l'air ambiant le 1er mai 62 les cbr
il tourne à la catastrophe
la bombe est bien plus puissante que
prévu
tout d'un coup ça a été le coup de
tonnerre et une poussière immense je
suis donc rentré dans mon laboratoire
j'ai vu mes mesures en veille si vous
voulez s'est écarté de plus en plus de
ma ligne de référence et j'ai vues si
vous voulez que il y avait un nuage
radioactif certainement d'une très très
forte radioactivité qui passait au sud
[Musique]
je met immédiatement mon masque à gaza
mon laboratoire et je vois mes camarades
du génie venir sur le laboratoire pour
savoir que faire j'enlève mon masque je
leur manque je leur dis vite quitte le
masque et ils me disent on an'a pas en
même temps est arrivé cinq ou six ans
que je ne connaissais pas avec leurs
combinaisons blanches qui se sont foutus
à poils qui m'ont demandé où était le
robinet d'eau et comme des fous furieux
ils se sont
souvenus comme des bêtes curieuses ça a
été la confirmation pour moi qui s'était
passé quelque chose de très rare c'est
la débandade le ministre des armées
pierre messmer et le ministre de la
recherche scientifique les ont pas volés
le ski venus assister à ce tir très
médiatisé fui vers l'aéroport militaire
à la fin des années 2000 une délégation
de scientifiques et d'anciens appelés a
été invité sur les lieux par les
autorités algériennes des lieux
abandonnés mais toujours accessible du
matériel radioactif a été laissé sur
place sans que les populations locales
ne soit informée du danger
il ya des gens qui ont creusé certains
ont pris des couvertures d'autres des
voitures détente et que sont devenus les
voitures
ils les ont démonté puis les ont
utilisés en pièces détachées
[Musique]
les images d'in eker montre un site qui
n'est pas sécurisé et auxquelles les
populations locales ont accès librement
malgré le danger le scientifique
français roland desbordes avait pu y
accéder
les opérateurs viennent toujours 68 60
ans a récupéré des câbles et font brûler
le plastique tout ce qui est compatible
pour récupérer le cuivre et ça il ya une
activité de récupération qui est
toujours aujourd'hui présentes sur le
site de cette visite sur le site d'in
eker le scientifique a rapporté un
échantillon rendu par la suite aux
autorités algériennes en plus avec du
plutonium
vous voyez sur ce pays une énorme
contamination en césium 137 il ya aussi
une contamination plutonium donc c'est
vraiment un déchets radioactifs à vie
longue qui n'a absolument rien à faire
dans l'environnement accessible à tout
le monde en 1962 les autorités
françaises ont minimisé l'impact sur les
populations locales notamment touareg
l'armée avait pourtant fait des relevés
à des centaines de kilomètres des lieux
de l'explosion
consciente de la dissémination des
retombées radioactives
le secret défense empêche toujours
d'accéder à toutes les preuves de la
contamination des populations et de
l'environnement
depuis des années l'observatoire des
armements basé à lyon se bat pour
obtenir la déclassification de documents
concernant les essais nucléaires en
algérie
comme les dizaines de pages de ce
dossier obtenu de haute lutte
ces documents en fait ils nous ont
surtout confirmé des choses qu'on savait
mais dont on n'avait pas les preuves
officielles puisque nous on avait des
éléments recueillis par les témoignages
ou par certains documents que les
personnes avaient gardé il nous avait
transmis mais il n'était pas officielle
donc on ne pouvait pas les utiliser
notamment dans les tribunaux pour
prouver que les personnes avaient été
impactées reconnaître ce que tout le
monde bien sûr scène et ne peut pas
prouver impliquerait forcément à
renforcer les indemnisations et
impliquerait surtout pour l'état
reconnaître qu'il a fauté quelque part
en janvier 2021 l'historien benjamin
stora a rendu au président bak rond un
rapport qui préconise d'ouvrir les
archives sur la période coloniale mais
les essais nucléaires français ne sont
pour l'heure pas concerner les régions
de reggane et du hoggar théâtre d'essais
nucléaires pendant 6 ans ont été
profondément contaminées dans certaines
zones la radioactivité ne commencera à
décroître que dans 24 mille ans